une de nos premières chansons là
quelques années de ça oui ça plaît
lecinéma ça
et alors je voudrais te demander
exceptionnellement ce soir pour la
première fois est peut-être pour la
dernière fois je le chante et à ta place
tu veux bien aller j'étais je vais me
payer mes toiles et une étoile aussi
chirurgie
[Applaudissements]
sur l'écran noir
nuit
et blanche
[Musique]
où je me fais du cinéma sans peu mieux
mais sans caméras par l'homme partir en
vacances
moi je me fais du cinéma
d
[Musique]
pendant neuf ans
pour te dire que je t'aime ya rien à
faire je cela
j'ai du coeur mais pas d'estomac
c'est pourquoi je prends ma revanche sur
l'écran noir de mes nuits blanches où je
me fais du cinéma
d
[Musique]
ja
d'abord un gros blanc
/
et on
angers
m
à noah
sion toi tu le prends
ah bon
oh
souriant je pense
m
[Applaudissements]
et puis ce dimanche
m
j'attends
oh
[Musique]
tu es trop noir mais
blanche où je me fais du cinéma
une fois deux fois dix fois vingt fois
je recommence la séquence
tu veux te tombent dans les bras
[Musique]
je tourne tous les soirs vie compris le
dimanche
parfois nous sonnes j'ouvre cette voie
vais je te prendre peuvent les hanches
comme sur l'écran de mai
blanc
non je te dis
mon
ça va
[Musique]
et je
temps
au ciné
et moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]